اعلان مقتل ثاني زعيم لتنظيم داعش خلال
عام واحد ضربه اخرى موجعه تلقاها التنظيم
على اثر اعلان مقتل زعيمه ابو الحسن
الهاشمي القرشي وذلك بعد محاصرته من قبل
مقاتلين محليين في بلده جاسم بسوريا
منتصفه اكتوبر الماضي
مقتل ابو الحسن الهاشمي اثار تساؤلات عده
حول تنظيم داعش وما هو السيناريو المنتظر
له اهي ضربه معنويه ام تنظيميه ستحمل
تداعيات على هيكله التنظيم نفسه
خبراء ذكر وان مقتل القيادات لن يؤثر على
التنظيم لا على المستوى الاستراتيجي او
على المستوى التمدد والانتشار لتنظيم داعش
الذي يرسم مسارات مستقبليه فيما وصفه
اخرون انه لن يمثل اي نهايه للتنظيم من
حيث الايديولوجيا او التخطيط
والاستراتيجيه القائمه له
لكن سرعه الاعلان عن تعيين ابو الحسين
الحسيني خالفا للقرش تعكس محاوله التنظيم
قطع الطريق على اي انشقاق وخلافات ويحمل
ايضا تعيين ابو الحسين
رساله مهمه للنظر الى ما عرف عنه وصفا
بانه متطرف عنيد وهو من الدائره المقربه
لابو الحسن القريشي
الا انه هو مع كل تصفيه او اختيار لزعماء
الصف الاول في التنظيم تبرز تساؤلات عن
السيناريوهات المستقبليه وتشير الخريطه
الامنيه والتنظيميه ان المسرح الاكثر
ترجيحا لعمليات داعش ستكون الصحراء
الافريقيه نظرا الى عوامل محليه اساسيه
اضافه الى عوامل اخرى اقليميه